the Battle Is Lost  yeah it's a big material advantage and a  huge attack so  and even white gives Bishop A5 checks  the check anyway yeah yeah just to show  that yeah I can do whatever I want yeah  why not yeah yeah I probably he will  resign within the next  very few moves  yes absolutely I mean what a stunning  way and not here back confirms how  dangerous he is he has won the  qualification he he won the leeches  qualification process yeah that's it  yeah designs Sensational Victory by  Modia back on the other hand because the  players will play the same position  twice this doesn't guarantee him yet any  Victory he is just one up and uh now Jan  needs to win the the second game to to  tie this course otherwise know the back  takes the mini match  yep wow yeah very I mean also in very  looked very convincing